Whether you are a fan from way back, or just got
into the series when it was added to HBO Max,
The Big Bang Theory remains one of the most
binge-worthy sitcoms in recent memory. With
a story that runs 12 seasons and 279 episodes,
the series makes for many hours of enjoyment,
as well as plenty of opportunities to spot
potential plot holes and continuity errors.
That's to be expected with any long-running
series, though, and spotting gaps in logic,
or very specific errors, can even add an
extra level of enjoyment to a rewatch.
Fans of The Big Bang Theory certainly seem
to think so, as they often take to Reddit to
share the plot holes they uncover deep in the
show's history. Unraveling how these mess-ups
affect the rest of the series, then, also adds
to the fun of seeking them out. One error,
recently uncovered by eagle-eyed Redditors,
carries big implications for the backstory of
Sheldon Cooper, not only on The Big Bang Theory,
but also the prequel series, Young Sheldon.
There's an issue with Sheldon's age, and it isn't
that the show hasn't told us when he was born.
Rather, the problem is that the show tells us when
Sheldon was born, but later contradicts that date.
It was referenced multiple times that Sheldon and
his twin sister Missy were born on February 26,
1980. However, as Reddit user dgiannak discovered,
the math of Sheldon's various life accomplishments
doesn't quite add up, if one examines Sheldon's
own accounting of his past in the first
season episode, "The Luminous Fish Effect."
After he gets fired from his job, Sheldon declares
he's not interested in getting it back, saying,
"I've spent the past three and a half years
staring at grease boards full of equations.
Before that, I spent four years
working on my thesis. Before that,
I was in college, and before
that, I was in the fifth grade."
Now, another established fact is that Sheldon,
being the difficult genius he is, started college
when he was eleven years old, a major plot point
in Young Sheldon. However, dgiannak notes that
when that timeline is added up — four years for
college, four for his PhD thesis, and three and
a half working before the beginning of the series
— that puts his age in "The Luminous Fish Effect"
at only 22. That's about five years shy of how
old he should be, at that point, which is 27.
This timeline fumble is likely nothing
more than the result of a mistake in the
script. But it's also not the first time
the show has had trouble pinning down
exactly when Sheldon was born. The show
also goofed on Sheldon's astrological sign.
Whether or not you believe that someone's
astrological sign has any correlation to
their personality, western astrology does work
off of a specific set of dates to categorize
people into one of twelve specific signs.
However, in the case of The Big Bang Theory,
the lines between someone's actual birthday and
their sign occasionally gets blurred. For example,
in the season one episode, "The Peanut Reaction,"
Penny is talking with Sheldon and Leonard
about the group's various zodiac signs.
She says,
"I was gonna do everybody's until Sheldon
went on one of his typical psychotic rants."
After Sheldon repeats his rant against the
legitimacy of astrology, Penny responds,
"Blah blah blah, a typical Taurus."
It's a funny line, but Sheldon's February 26th
birthday makes him a Pisces, not a Taurus.
Penny herself even confirms this fact in the
season 8 episode, "The Intimacy Acceleration."
After learning that it's
Sheldon's birthday, she responds,
"That is so funny. I would never
have pegged you for a Pisces."
This might all seem like it's fixating extra hard
on Sheldon's birth date, so to switch things up,
have a look at the time the show couldn't
decide where Sheldon was born, instead of when.
Sheldon's mother, Mary Cooper, became one of The
Big Bang Theory's best-loved supporting characters
because of her Texas-sized personality,
and the fact that she and Sheldon
are comically different people. One of the
first things that viewers learn about Mary
is that she gave birth to Sheldon in
a rather unconventional location. This
occurs in the episode "The Luminous Fish
Effect," wherein Mary comes to town to
try and shake Sheldon out of the depressive
episode he falls into after losing his job.
While talking to his friends
about her son, Mary says,
"I'll tell ya, I love the boy to death,
but he has been difficult since
he fell out of me at the K-Mart."
Just one season later, though, viewers
were already given an alternative location
for Sheldon's birth. In the season 2 episode,
"The Lizard-Spock Expansion," Sheldon asserts
that he was born at the fictional Lawrence
Memorial Hospital, not at a department store.
So, after all of that, here's
the lowdown on Sheldon's birth:
he was born on February 26 and sometime
in April, between the years 1980-1985,
at the K-Mart inside the Lawrence Memorial
Hospital. Glad that's all cleared up!
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.